all right Alan Dru here and today we're
going to be talking about five rapid
ways to grow your email list to a TH or
more in 90 days I wish I would have had
these cuz I would have grown my list to
a th000 a lot faster than I did so I'm
going to give you my best strategies
tactics five of them today let's Dive
Right In number one is a very uncommon
used way to grow your email list and
that is speaking on podcast but this is
one of my favorite ways to grow your
email list for one very simple reason is
podcasts are
evergreen qualified content now let me
break down what that means Evergreen
meaning it's up there forever when
somebody is doing a podcast and they're
interviewing you on their podcast right
that podcast is going to be up there on
Spotify on Apple podcast on YouTube
Forever meaning people can find it time
and time and time and time again so it's
not dead content tomorrow whereas if you
post on Instagram or Twitter or anything
like that that content goes up today but
dies tomorrow right you people are not
finding that it's not a search engine
where on podcast they find it forever
and so that accessibility to join your
list is not massive at first but it is a
slow burn and it sustains over time so
the more podcast you speak on the more
you have yourself out there and the
second thing is qualified meaning
somebody just spent an hour hour
listening to your story or your
background or whatever it is you were
talking about on that podcast and then
they're willing to join your list so
that's a qualified person meaning that's
a really quality person who's willing to
not just listen to you for an hour but
then join your list to listen more to
you so that guy is going to become that
guy or gal is going to become a super
fan of you more likely than anyone else
so podcasts are great for ever green and
great for qualifying great people on
your list how many times can I say great
number two is list swinging all right
this is a I think that's a Daniel
throtle term but list swinging is a way
to get your email list out to another
set of qualified people again the key
thought here being you want quality
people on your list okay speed is fun
growing your list fast is fun but you
don't want crap on your list you want
good people on your list so finding
people in your Niche other people set
sending emails in your Niche like for me
right I talk about copyrighting content
so I try to connect with other
copywriters in my Niche right who are
also talking to copywriters or other
people who teach copywriters like the
Ben settles of the world the Daniel
throstles of the world the Kevin Rogers
of the world those guys and if you can
now those guys are bigger names you can
find some smaller names in your list you
network with these guys and you propose
and strike a deal hey if can I advertise
on your list can you talk to people
about me tell story in exchange for
money or you list swing where I
advertise on your list and you advertise
on my list and we tell each other about
each other's followers and that's list
hacking list swinging so now you're
borrowing the trust of that other person
and they're promoting you and your email
list to Their audience you can do this
by paying the person I'll give you
$1,000 to promote me $5,000 to promote
me whatever
or you can do this by helping each other
you promote me I promote you this really
works when you have equal size lists I
have a th000 you have a th000 I have
10,000 you have 10,000 right um
otherwise it doesn't really work I have
a th000 you have 200,000 will you help
each other that's not how that works so
you want to find people in your Niche
who have similar list size to you and
you offer to cross promote that's a
great way to grow your list number three
is plugging your email list on under
your content okay great way to do this
if you're on LinkedIn if you're on
Twitter if you're on medium things like
that right you're already writing
content and so a great way is at the end
of your content whether it's a short
form tweet or a medium article or
whatever tell people to join your list
this is the most obvious miss that I see
people do all the time and honestly this
grew 50 to 60% of my list right and so
one of the best ways that I like to do
this is with a lead mag okay I like to
offer my audience something in exchange
for joining my list so I'll write a
short form post a short form medium
article and I'll say hey if you like
this content you're going to love my
copyrighting Catalyst which if you don't
have it you can get it in the
description below you're going to love
my copyrighting Catalyst which you could
get for free just put your email in and
I'll send it over to you so I plug that
at the bottom of all my tweets at the
bottom of all my threads uh medium
articles whatever it is whatever you're
on LinkedIn and that's a simple way to
find people who are already interested
in your content they like what you're
writing and then you get them over to
your list right all funnels should lead
to your email list especially the
volatile land of social media where the
algorithms rain and you can barely reach
the same people you reached yesterday
it's a horrible place to be you want to
get them from social media to your email
list by plugging your lead magnet under
every single post you do which leads me
to number four way of growing your list
and honestly the way that is used most
often but I have a disclaimer with this
number four is doing a giveaway okay a
giveaway is basically creating a lead
magnet of some sort like for me again I
wrote copyrighting Catalyst because my
audience loves to learn copyrighting so
I took the best copyrighting tips I know
and have learned over the years and have
studied I packaged them all together and
that is a lead magnet that is a way that
I get you to go grab it and give me your
email address then you are are on my
list and I give you more valuable
content through my emails okay but to do
that you could do a giveaway you package
that and you say hey for the next 48
hours only whatever I'm doing this plus
a bonus or whatever or before the price
goes up there's all kinds of ways to do
that but you could do a giveaway where
you are now having people like comment
retweet share your post things like that
in exchange for your lead magnet to join
your list okay here's the thing this
works really well and is the fastest way
to grow your list giveaways could go
viral especially if the thing that
you're giving away is super valuable but
a couple disclaimers one it needs to be
incredibly relevant to your audience I.E
I could do an iPhone giveaway and say
I'm giving away this iPhone for
everybody who joins my list and it would
explode I would have a ton of people but
they would be crap right it would be
crap people who don't really care about
copyrighting who just want free stuff
and are interested in iPhone not me and
not my email right so that's a crap
giveaway if you're going to do a
giveaway giveaway is something that
solves a problem that your audience
currently has okay like for me a
giveaway that I'll probably do in the
future even though there's a million of
them I do them differently is something
around headlines hooks people in the
copyrighting space like you usually have
a really hard time coming up with great
headlines and great Hooks and so I'm
going to give you my structure my
formula you to come up with great
headlines and great hooks without
spending a ton of time on it I'm going
to post that as a giveaway and people
who have that problem will respond will
give me their email will join my list
and therefore that giveaway will add a
lot of emails to my email list so it's
got to be relevant it's got to be
helpful and it's got to be sharable
which leads me to number five number
five is the creator Network okay this is
a convert kit specific thing so if
you're not on convert kit there are
other platforms I understand gumroad and
beehive and Berserker mail and lots of
other platforms but for me specifically
I use convertkit and it actually uh has
helped me Skyrocket my list with the
Creator Network so I can't not share
this with you the Creator network is an
ecosystem of other newsletters and
creators online in convertkit where you
share each other's newsletter and you
preview each other's newsletter so
there's a lot of high quality people
browsing the Creator Network who come
across me for copywriting right I'm in
the copywriting section they could
search copyrighting and I would come up
you also have the opportunity to get
featured and that happened to me my
newsletter got featured on the Creator
Network because of what I do and how
fast I'm growing and things like that
and it's helpful to a lot of people it
skyrocketed my list cuz I was on the
feature page but ever since then even
before then I was getting a lot of
people just being in the Creator Network
and that is a really underrated place to
get high quality people to join your
list so if you're on convertkit make
sure you have your convertkit creator
network profile done your landing page
done in there and you can start
networking with other people in that
area which leads me to the bonus way I
have a bonus number six you didn't see
that coming that is recommendations okay
so if you're on the Creator network if
you're on convertkit if you're on
beehive whatever it is substack things
like that you can do recommendations
where actually when somebody subscribes
to your email list you could actually
set up other people's emails that you
recommend so when you subscribe to my
list there's three or four other
copywriters that I recommend hey if you
like me you'll like these guys right and
you could go subscribe to them but
there's a bunch I have over 50 people
recommending my list and I get a ton of
subscribers like that where they say oh
you like my list well you'll definitely
like Allen's list and so I get a ton of
people just cuz they recommend me so you
can connect with people in the creative
Network on your platforms and say hey
I'll recommend you you recommend me
we're in similar initia so now every
time they get a new subscriber you get
shown to that new subscriber which is
moving them to your list growing it
hitting that th as fast as possible and
you are officially crushing the game I
hope this serves you well you Skyrocket
your list you grab copyrighting cataly
speaking of growing our list you better
be on my list Allen dru.com
newsletter and I'll catch you next time
H which one was your favorite 1 2 3 4 5
6 which one I would I would like to drop
it in the comments while you're before
you head out drop it in the comments
which tip was your favorite which one
blew your mind or are you a maestro and
you already knew all these in fact you
should educate me how do you grow your
list what is your tip put it in the
comments